[Music]
in artists verse corporation news but
sometimes artists are the corporation I
had a business manager businessman like
jay-z let me handle my business man
artists or artists become the
corporation like what happened at maker
studios here here oh so you're either
you either die a hero you live long
enough to be the villain from the game
Batman which Batman the one the without
he's wears a dark suit sick wow he's a
super nerd night Nicky that is my
favorite movie I actually thought that
was a quote from some philosopher until
like recently have you seen have you
seen the movie heat yes dude good
they're so similar it's about Parenthood
in my life right now is my kid my older
son is cool enough to send me new
trailers be like yo you seen the movie
trailers and we don't watch it's way
better than when he was a baby
yeah but then you show over decent movie
so whatever did that was one time
[Music]
Oh submitted by a dairy man milkman
cheese man almond milk man that's me
almond milk is great [ __ ] the water two
gallons million gallon may be gallons it
takes to raise a cow a lot more users
hose we're gonna be fine bro
it's called desalination plants bro
we're gonna be what kind of milk you do
something's getting apart this is breast
milk if you like [ __ ] really harm Jeff
if you like salad rodents are getting
killed in the [ __ ] fields and [ __ ]
just well I like soy milk that's right
that's silk soy milk gives dudes titties
so I'm yeah that's
cinnamon rolls mercedes-benz is suing
several several street artists after
they questioned copyright infringement
street artists Deborah feeding Banksy
will never get them artists like painted
a Mercedes Benz or something like on a
mural or something else probably dissing
Mercedes Benz for being like rich
people's stuff no we're over - maybe
because maybe because a lot of [ __ ]
drivers [ __ ] drive Mercedes Benz
that's for sure
we're you're a Mercedes Benz that's like
a Honda they're literally takes away my
mystique of it like everyone has
advanced you're like February why are we
like I think this is ballin I always cut
off by mercedes-benz and BMW really it
Minds viewing WS and Audi's BMWs and
Audi's you could go to hell on a freakin
handbasket good bart has an Audi you
have a party's a great deal has a BMW
I've been in the car when Bart cutoff
Halla people did so it's all good I
think the better than you and I'm like
[ __ ] you I got a Honda Civic Hybrid I
like it I chose this I like it to this
moment really high because we are here
what's hives
that's a hybrid like a future no one
thinks about that car they used to steal
it medallions off of the hoods of them
no I was watching Mad Men Jaguar used to
be like a like a crappy car and part of
their job was to basically convince rich
people that even though this is probably
gonna break down
you're still ballin yep we'll name what
and that's super sleek like it probably
is the most sports car sports car out
there like it says I got a little bread
I mean they went through a rebranding
that's why in the beginning tell that
would break down a lot and then yeah
thank you so much and then everybody
anyway so what happened here um this so
Mercedes they post meta status on their
instagrams hey this thing it's like a
campaign are there new what is it
all in there a Jeep and the street
artist behind there is the person so
what happened here is like the street
artist contacted Mercedes and said like
hey you know we didn't get any
compensation for you using our art and
it's like predominate like yes pretty
they're your eyes definitely drawn to
the art before the car oh this cars kind
of funky until they could have turned
that into a color or something like they
could have not SETI's was suing the guy
it's the other way around
no so when the artist this is it like
that is fire though when the artists
contact with Mercedes the artists are
saying that that's when like when they
were in talks behind their back where
Sadie was filing a lawsuit against them
because they said that they they didn't
have any copy my copyright infringement
like any anything the to pretty much go
after Mercedes so Mercedes jumped the
gun first and one
after them a pre-emptive lawsuit if I
see you first
they're saying that they that there is
no copyright infringement here so once
you them what are they were the guys so
what are they they have no right or that
they have the right to future street art
and advertisements and isn't that a
defense yeah yeah I don't understand
that tax I was just as confused okay I
don't understand that do the art from
our Instagram photo on this wall dare
you come after us we have the right to
use your yeah but I don't know if that
can be a lawsuit because what I can see
them doing that shady is if they're if
they know that there's no copyright on
that they can actually file the
copyright could take it
oh off of their own art genius yeah they
can copyright that image I know I got
sued and then I countersuit so you can
counter sue yeah I don't know the
wording is interesting because I was
confused too because I said that the
artist said they sued us claiming they
did not violate any copyright laws and
are asking the court to rule that we
have no rights against them that's
what's happening here
mmm they filed the lawsuit secretly
while they were talking to them waiting
to hear back from them so there are
three artists named Daniel Bombardier
max from fromage Oh and James
babbles Louis how can you file in secret
don't you have to be served yeah if
there's a lot yes they were not openly
telling them that we're going through
with this process and maybe they're
talking it out as if like Jake ended up
like let's make a deal
yeah yeah I said that I could see a
corporation doing that yeah a friend of
mine he got sued by um Under Armour he
was selling his name is Ike Williams who
selling shirts that say I will like I
will do this in that and Under Armour
suit him like hey that's our statement
he was like but my name was I Williams
are like man we don't nobody care about
your name we're suing you and he lost
because yeah because they have been
selling clothes with that I will train I
will do this you got it
you you could name a kid Under Armour
and then you can do that hey my kids man
but you still lose that it's like
Michael Jordan or Nike that's that's why
I agree with it yeah I think your friend
should have been sued out of existence
you're not gonna be just start opening
companies of under everyone's names and
then suing people if they try to use
their name anywhere but nobody lost
though no I know no I'm saying it's like
parking a website all right exactly I
mean they already do that so I think in
the business world to the word like what
is ethical to us is different like in
common
if we sue each other because of the the
uses of [ __ ] this image or name or
whatever we take it personally offensive
right it's just a game to them it is a
game and then it's also a way so let me
just make money or to or to hurt their
competition yeah it's a strategy it's
another yeah it's another form of
warfare do a bunch of years ago I was I
had this trolling idea where I would
copyright you know the trollface image
that 4chan now these guys pass around
yeah I was like I'm gonna copyright this
[ __ ] and then all [ __ ] all I'll be
like hey you can't use this [ __ ] cuz
it's mine even though I didn't make it
as a way to troll for can't but then I
was like do I really want to troll for
time why would you want a troll tonight
exactly but I like trolling everybody
sounds like just to be funny but then
I'm like and maybe not this one
you don't want to die I have to save you
from now on yeah you didn't have to save
a file to save them from a lot of trolls
oh sure like what's the story okay so
like oh we shouldn't even talk about it
I don't think no no I don't think yeah
we'll talk about it off camera you can
talk okay one of them that I had to stop
him doing is like he had a bulletproof
vest on and he was gonna get a shot at
point-blank range
did you doing that with the book I did
hear about that well that's not a
bulletproof vest though that's up a book
from one point blank range with a
watermelon not your light body yes
exactly
oh I thought you were thinking that cut
a watermelon for everybody I was like
that's pretty good
like that's pretty very viral that's one
that'll still kill you the other one
would have killed them too but I'll tell
you I stopped cuz yeah I got man my wife
is very very right associated with the
FBI were like you would have definitely
gotten killed
yes my buddy's friends with some tier 1
operators who was like did this idea
wash to get you killed
and then I was like okay I'll listen to
you know it was like months after I
already stopped it he was pissed because
I still wanted to do it yeah where would
improve that to see if it might be dead
without your wife I'll tell you guys
off-camera I can't say thank you but
also the bullet might not go through but
the damage it does to your chest and it
might break your ribs and all these yeah
it's like you could I know Steve didn't
think about that
you don't have to die for it to be a bad
idea yeah also being really great brain
when I'm rich I got next electron ideas
and I'm worried about all the veto a lot
of those too I got some good [ __ ] you
can't leave them alone for 5 likes Steve
what are you beating about nothing
nothing I not think about anything
you nervous for your future kids I'm not
because he's also like he's he's like a
guy he's an ideas guy but he's gotta
have someone like produce the idea so
like unless he has that middleman
officer Michael Scott would have an idea
and they'd have to stop it before he got
too far along that is stee but I know
you can't do that it's like pouring gas
like I'm gonna spill out Nicky in flames
but the gas is going up to you
[Laughter]
[Music]